we are cleared into the area verified
cameras are on all right here we go
three
two one
here comes some g's
there's five g's
all right
that was awesome
i wasn't ready to make a sequel until we
had a special story
worthy of a sequel and until technology
evolved so we could delve deeper into
the experience of a fighter pilot
the first movie became something that
changed a generation
so this is exciting to come back and get
those jets again
we worked with the navy and the top gun
school to formulate how to shoot it
practically because if we're going to do
it we're going to fly in the f-18s
the aviation sequences had to be real
so our actors went through three months
of ruling training
the navy says if you eject you have to
be able to survive in the water so we
had to go through that challenging
underwater program
it's intense you're flipped inverted and
you're having to try and get out
from there tom designed this
all-encompassing aviation training for
all the actors
i started them out in a single-engine
airplane
to build up their spatial awareness
inside the aircraft
next we took them to the l-39 and they
went and flew aerobatics to feel what
it's like in a
jet from there they'd graduate to the
f-18 super hornet and actually launching
off an aircraft carrier
the actors also had to learn how to run
the cameras because when they're up in
the jet they have to direct themselves
essentially okay
i had to really teach them
cinematography and the lighting so that
they understood what's gonna look good
on camera is great everybody thought it
would be impossible for actors to really
be in the jets
but that's the gift that tom gave us
that by the time we got up there
we could handle it
definitely the most amazing thing i've
ever done all the training 100 prepared
i'm very proud of what we all accomplish
each one of them are extraordinary
it still blows my mind
that we've done this
there's nothing like it
[Music]
you